question de la dette ne serait ce que
partiel est totalement impensable c'est
pas si facile d'annuler la dette et la
limite c'est quoi c'est la planche à
billets qui aura en contrepartie
[Musique]
où
l afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'europe ou les états
unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus au nord proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement puisse être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population ça allait
beaucoup plus facilement puisqu'on
venait de sortir d'une d'une épidémie
d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui était si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs est qu en afrique puis ça
pourrait être très très difficile pour
[Musique]
un week-end de liberté de détente pour
les français mais sous stricte
surveillance des autorités pour la
première fois depuis huit semaines les
français ont commencé à profiter de
l'extérieur sans restriction mais
prudence sinon ce sera retour chez soi a
averti le ministre de l'intérieur en
déplacement en seine maritime
christophe castaner qui a de nouveau
fait l' inverse de ce qui leur donne aux
français on va le voir
une bouffée d'air également dans le
reste de l'europe reprise du football
professionnel en allemagne
rassemblements de plus de trois cents
personnes autorisées en république
tchèque à partir du 25 mai
âge et commerces qui commence également
à rouvrir en irlande
dublin va imposer une quarantaine
obligatoire à toute personne arrivant de
l'étranger
pour l'espagne ce sera volontaire et
l'italie elles annoncent l'ouverture de
ses frontières aux touristes de l'union
européenne à partir du 3 juin loto
isolement de 14 jours sera donc supprimé
la france à la traîne dans la course au
vaccin contre le collège 19 peu
d'acteurs nationaux sont en pointe dans
ce domaine faute de moyens à l'exception
de l'institut pasteur
ce matin la ministre de la recherche a
estimé qu'un vaccin ne sera sans doute
pas être disponibles avant 18 mois
l'agencé européenne du médicament elle
table sur un délai d'un an
le président américain lui espère un
vaccin avant la fin de l'année et peut
être même avant a déclaré hier donald
trump
depuis les jardins de la maison blanche
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi pour la
première fois depuis huit semaines les
français peuvent de nouveau bouger dans
un rayon de 100 kilomètres et profitez
du week end certaines plages forêts de
france ont rouvert avec des restrictions
avec l'espoir aussi d'une reprise
touristique pour les professionnels
nageurs plaisanciers ou pêcheurs à pied
ont donc retrouvé le chemin des plages
de la méditerranée à l'atlantique à la
manche mais interdit d'y poser sa
serviette
les plages sont réservés à un usage
dynamique au total ce sont plus de 200
plages qui sont de nouveau accessibles
en france reportage à hyères d'isabelle
ferrières et d'alexis combres regarder
malgré un temps orageux les sourires
rayonne sur la plage de l'almanarre une
des huit plages de la ville de nouveau
accessible depuis ce samedi matin au
public autorisé à se rendre de nouveau
les hyérois et les habitants des
environs peuvent même y poser leurs
serviettes et faire bronzette à
condition toutefois de respecter les
mesures barrières
c'est ce qu'on appelle une plage
statique tous les sports nautiques ils
sont également autorisées sauf s'ils
sont collectifs règles de distanciation
physique oblige
de quoi faire le bonheur des varois et
faire oublier l'ennui tu joues
confinement ça crée un soulagement on
est détendu on est serein voilà c'est
une façon de décompresser par rapport au
quotidien et à la vie de tous les jours
j'ai profité de cette ouverture des
plages pour tout de suite prendre un
bain et et nagé pendant une heure avec
mes petites plaquettes l'a donc un peu à
la méthode triathlon et je peux vous
dire que ça fait un bien fou hein
on attendait avec impatience de s'être
ouverture parce que à la maison c'est
long c'est lent depuis deux mois
moi qui aime bien me baigner quel que
soit le temps ça donnait très dur
d'attendre
oui c'est une nouvelle que qu'on a
attendu parce qu'on comprenait pas bien
pourquoi les plages étaient fermés alors
que les centres villes étaient ouverts
et que quand on était confiné les gens
étaient complètement collés les uns aux
autres en train de marcher alors que sur
une plage et de la place donc là on ne
pas couler mais pour s'assurer du bon
respect des règles deux agents de la
ville sillonnent le bord de mer pour
repérer celles et ceux qui tenteraient
de les enfreindre effectivement
légèrement le droit de se poser sur le
sable avec leurs serviettes baignade
après bon pas de pas de réunion de plus
de 10 personnes en gardant à distance
pas de barbecue et je vous dis nous on
n'est pas là pour pour se disputer pour
engueuler les gens mais on écoule s'il
ya quoi que ce soit on appelle l on
appelle la police municipale farniente
marche pas de louer leur pêche après des
semaines passées chez soi les habitants
de la ville reprennent progressivement
possession de la méditerranée
le gouvernement a annoncé cette semaine
une enveloppe de 18 milliards d'euros
pour aider le secteur du tourisme qui
est à l'arrêt depuis plus de deux mois
pour les commerçants les restaurateurs
et les hôteliers l'annnonce du retour de
l'activité est un soulagement activité
qui va reprendre début juin illustration
dans la manche au mont-saint-michel
voyez ce reportage de pierre pissavy
yvernault et genre de demory le site lui
a déjà rouvert regarder le retour des
touristes mont saint michel
doucement mais sûrement depuis lundi les
portes de ce site exceptionnel sont de
nouveau ouvertes après 55 jours de
confinement inquiets depuis à plus de
deux mois pour la survie de leur
entreprise
le retour des visiteurs l annonce du
premier ministre en faveur d'un plan
massif pour venir en aide au secteur est
un véritable soulagement pour les
acteurs économiques du monde la
possibilité à cette échéance du mois de
juin alors le 2
mais peu après et
d'envisager la réouverture en zone verte
des cafés et des restaurants
parce que c'est un élément très
important
le mont saint michel est un lieu où on
vient aisément passer la journée et
souvent même quelques jours donc
l'absence d'activités de restauration
même si les hôtels pourrait ouvrir ce
qui n'est pas le cas mais l'absence de
restauration est très dommageable de moi
donc que les touristes n'avaient pas
foulé les pavés et d'un des sites les
plus visités de france pour les
commerçants et restaurateurs le temps a
semblé bien long
certains auraient même perdu jusqu'à un
tiers de leur chiffre d'affaires annuel
si tous les commerces n'ont pas ouvert
leurs portes certains ont tenu tout de
même à être présent pour les visiteurs
je vais pas vous dire non ça nous
inquiète et c'est sûr façon là c'est
deux mois qu'ils sont très gros parce
qu'il y avait des vacances en avril et
au mois de mai tous les ponts c est le
temps il n'a pas super voit donc
logiquement il y aurait dû avoir
beaucoup beaucoup de monde le mont saint
michel qui peut parfois accueillir plus
de 20000 personnes quotidiennement
semble donc bien vide en cette belle
journée du mois de mai l'abbaye demeure
fermée au public encore quelques
semaines les visiteurs privilégiés
viennent d'un rayon de moins de 100 km
conformément aux mesures sanitaires à
des touristes pas si malheureux de
flâner peu nombreux dans ce décor
majestueux puis ça fait un peu triste
quand même
les boutiques sont ouvertes c'est drôle
mais c'est agréable pour se promener par
c'est vrai que le fait de
défricher aujourd'hui ça permet de mieux
profiter
la visite parce que on est moins
bousculés on a on a plus d' approche à
tous c'est vrai que c'est dommage pour
ceux qui ne peuvent pas être là non plus
c'est un petit peu tristounet quand même
hein on aime bien quand même qu'ils
aient un peu de foule quand même bon et
puis pour trouver les commerçants qui
ont quand même perdu pas mal d'argent
tout est fermé sa part quand est-ce
qu'ils vont rouvrir c'est un peu tôt
pour tout le monde ça permet d'apprécier
le mois le moins de monde loin de nous
de prendre le temps de prendre le temps
d'apprécier le paysage points 2 mais
c'est vrai que c'est super beau et pour
faire respecter les mesures sanitaires
un sens de circulation a été mise en
place au monde tout s'organise donc pour
un retour progressif à la normale est
espéré pour le 2 juin prochain et pour
appeler les français à l'ordre le
ministre de l'intérieur s'est déplacé
dans deux communes de seine maritime ce
matin christophe castaner qui a de
nouveau lancé un avertissement aux
français s'ils ne sont pas disciplinés
ils seront de nouveau assignée à
résidence
pourtant plusieurs images vous voyez
montre le ministre sans masque ni gestes
barrières dans des regroupements à plus
de 10 personnes qui plus est à plus de
200 km dans une zone classée rouge cette
photo et c'est une photo qui date de la
semaine dernière on vous montrera la
bonne dans la prochaine édition
l'accès aux plages et d'aujourd'hui
interview mais sur proposition des mains
avec l'engagement des maires des
collectivités locales sous réserve d'un
aménagement qui garantit la sécurité
citoyens sur ces pages le préfet a la
possibilité d'ouvrir l'aménagement
l'accès à la plage près de 290 arrêtés
ont été pris hier pour préparer la
réouverture des pages c'est un important
de travail c'est important travail qui
était en amont pourquoi parce que nous
devons rester d'abord dans la logique
d'un déconfinement progressif c'est ce
que j'ai voulu en venant ici ce matin
salué cet aménagement simple ces
principes simples celui d'une page
dynamique où l'on vient on peut
pratiquer une activité sportive on peut
pratiquer la pêche mais par contre on
n'occupe à l'espace public pendant des
heures en étant comme on le fait
quelquefois et comme on l'a fait en
temps normal sur les plages avec le non
respect de la distance à sion physique
en zone rouge la plupart des parcs et
des jardins demeurent fermés mais les
grands espaces forestiers eux peuvent de
nouveau accueillir les promeneurs vous
voyez c'est le cas à rambouillet écoutez
les promeneurs on est venu ici avec
quelques amis parce qu'on sait que c'est
un espace de verdure assez large et que
ça à moins de 100 km de paris où on
habite donc permettre un peu de sortir
du cadre de la ville profité du début
des confinement mais en respectant les
distances
ça fait plaisir de pouvoir voir aller un
peu plus loin que 1 km depuis depuis
plusieurs semaines quoi c'est surtout
dans les échanges se changer d'ère un
petit peu sur l'état d'esprit mais pour
les enfants ça fait du ca fait ça leur
fait du bien aussi et quand on commence
à bien tourner en rond
ça fait du bien ça fait du bien et si
c'est important je pense pour tout le
monde c'est vrai qu'on est heureux
d'être dans la nature nouveau puisque
lock up on apprécié on a pu marcher
trois ou quatre ou cinq kilomètres à
l'intérieur de ce parc qui plus calme
que jamais on a bien joué le jeu du
confinement peut classer la première
provient autant c'est pas tout à fait la
vraie vie mes débuts en week-end qui
marque aussi le retour de la
contestation des gilet jaune ils sont
venus dénoncer la gestion de la crise
sanitaire par le gouvernement notamment
un rassemblement le dernier
rassemblement des gilet jaune de
remonter au 14 mars dernier c'était
l'acte 69
la plupart des préfectures ont interdit
ces manifestations voyez les précisions
de notre reporter n'avait jamais razak
retour en demi-teinte pour les gilet
jaune tout a commencé aux alentours de
midi aujourd'hui lorsque plusieurs
groupes de gilet jaune ont tenté de
manifester à châtelet au louvre certain
sur les champs elysées ils ont
rapidement été dispersés par les forces
de police présentes sur place ils ont
donc débarqué en début d'après-midi sur
cette place de la république
des tensions ont éclaté en début d'après
midi entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre lorsque des policiers ont menacé
une dizaine de manifestants et les ont
empêchés de quitter les lieux
compte tenu du contexte sanitaire les
gilets jaunes avaient prévu de
manifester en respectant les gestes
barrière en respectant la distanciation
sociale et les forces de police sur
place n'ont rien voulu entendre et puis
elles leur ont rapidement demandé de
quitter lé lieu des forces de police qui
n'ont pas forcément de leur côté
respecté ni les gestes barrière ni la
distanciation social puisqu'il certains
d'entre eux se trouvaient à moins d'un
mètre les uns et des autres des gilet
jaune qui est bien reviennent sur le
terrain pour protester contre la gestion
calamiteuse 1 qu'il qualifie de
calamiteuse la gestion du gouvernement
de cette crise est liée au kobus 19 le
coc u19 qui a fait en france en plus de
27 mille morts les gilets jaunes
également rassemblés à lyon et voyez
cette fois les précisions de notre
reporter sur place qu'il a faim amouzou
ils étaient une petite centaine de
manifestants rassemblés place du
maréchal lyautey ici à lyon des
manifestants qui voyant ce premier
samedi de déconfinement l'occasion de
reprendre le mouvement des gels et jaune
mais surtout de demander des comptes au
gouvernement
qantas et considère comme une gestion
catastrophique de la crise sanitaire
plusieurs questions pourquoi avoir
maintenu le premier tour des élections
municipales ou encore pourquoi avoir
selon eux mis en danger le personnel
hospitalier
après 55 jours de confinement et
plusieurs samedi il n'a pas été possible
de manifester leur colère reste intacte
écoutez quand on en a plein des
revendications d'arrêter de donner des
primes aux gens pour faire des effets de
com alors mettre des vrais moyens pour
travailler depuis les années 90 on a
perdu je sais pas combien de lits
si l'hôpital public ce qui nous a
conduits être confiné parce qu'en fait
si on avait un hôpital qui marchait
comme il faut les gens auraient gardé
leur liberté on nous a privés d'une
liberté pour des moyens de femmes pour
des raisons de rentabilité on peut pas
rendre un hôpital rentable c'est comme
ça donc déjà pour moi ça c'est le
premier truc après la mille choses
contre lesquelles on est en colère on
est toujours dans une crise sanitaire
mais je trouve que c'est important aussi
d'être là pour dénoncer certaines
actions du gouvernement notamment
pendant confinement qu'on a pu voir à
une gestion assez lamentable de la crise
et c'est pour ça aussi qu'on peut
présent pour revendiquer ce qu'on
revendique depuis plus eu plusieurs
plusieurs mois aujourd'hui ça fait deux
mois enfermés on a le droit d'aller à la
plage mais on n'a pas le droit d'aller
chez paou on doit aller travailler
on doit poser des gamins à l'école donc
ça fait rien qu'on crève nos gamins mais
on doit pas venir manifester
donc en fait c'est comme ils veulent
c'est comme ils veulent et lassé des
contrôles d'identité dont ses 135 euros
d'amande
donc nous on va nourrir les caisses de
l'état on est les pigeons à maquereau et
ben non en poche chez nous une première
mobilisation qui a duré à peine plus
d'une heure puisque les forces de l'anp
qui étaient là en présence conséquente
ont systématiquement disperser la foule
ils ont procédé à des contrôles
d'identité on les a vus donner plusieurs
amendes on a d'ailleurs assisté à deux
interpellations
les manifestants se sont retrouvés
quelques heures après avenue de la
république
alors que toute manifestation dans cette
avenue était interdite par la préfecture
l'objectif de cette première
mobilisation après confinement était de
voir si ce déconfinement pouvait rimer
avec retour des luttes sociales
il semblerait que toute manifestation
sera très difficile à mener dans les
jours qui viennent
en espagne le premier ministre a annoncé
vouloir prolonger l'état d'urgence pour
un mois un état d'urgence initialement
instaurée le 14 mars dernier et
plusieurs fois reconduit
il aurait dû prendre fin le 24 mai et
l'italie elle a annoncé qu'elle allait
rouvrir ses frontières aux touristes à
l'union de
l'union européenne à partir du 3 juin
prochain l'italie qui comme la grèce a
ouvert les plages et la médiane la
gestion des plages est devenu un
véritable casse tête notamment sur les
côtes italiennes
les entreprises du secteur touristique
doivent jouer les équilibristes
l'italie qui a payé un lourd tribut face
à l'épidémie de coronavirus est
confronté à un dilemme préserver le
tourisme tout en limitant les risques de
contagion à l'aller retour à ne pas
rater nous nous sommes préparés à la
réouverture selon la réglementation en
vigueur en ce moment donc éloignement et
aux masques et gants rouges elle de
désinfection avec des panneaux de la
manière la plus agréable possible afin
de ne pas créer plus de stress pour les
clients ce que vous choisi de passer
quelques jours au bord de la distance de
moins 4 mètres et demi entre les
parasols des infections de tous les
espaces communs comme les douches et les
bars distributeurs de gel hydro
alcoolique dans les zones de passage
entrées et sorties distinctes ces règles
imposées par rome vont devoir être
respectés pour passer un été à l'abri du
coc vie 19 tout en flânant sur les
plages italiennes
les autorités envisagent même d'obliger
le port du masque sur le sable jusqu'à
l'entrée dans l'eau un terme emprunté à
dakar et paris
nous sommes prêts à accueillir les
touristes qui viendront sur la côte de
la dernière ces dernières semaines nous
sommes efforcés d'attache des plages
mais audel et nos campings à l'urgence
sanitaire actuelle nous sommes en mesure
de garantir la salubrité des vacances en
bord de mer
bli ga l'empiré la chaloupe tu avais la
vague à accueillir des vacanciers et
appliquer les mesures strictes pour
éviter une saison estivale totalement
blanche l'autorisent
représente une manne non négligeable
pour l'économie italienne fesses pour
cent du pib
l'industrie du tourisme subit déjà des
pertes énormes à cause de la pandémie
même constat en grèce qui se prépare
également à recevoir les vacanciers cet
été
dès lundi les citoyens pourront se
déplacer dans toute la grèce
continentale et se rendre en crète en
bateau sur l'île d'eubée
pour les étrangers il faudra encore
attendre un peu pour plonger les pieds
dans le sable chaud des plages grecque
air france a annoncé la reprise
progressive des vols entre paris et
athènes
à partir du samedi 23 mai la france à la
traîne dans la course au vaccin contre
locaux vides 19 peu d'acteurs nationaux
sont en pointe dans ce domaine faute de
moyens à l'exception de l'institut
pasteur
ce matin la ministre de la recherche a
estimé qu'un vaccin ne sera sans doute
pas disponibles avant 18 mois
l'agencé européenne du médicament elle
table sur un délai d'un an
le président américain lui espère un
vaccin avant la fin de l'année et
peut-être même avant a déclaré donald
trump hier depuis les jardins de la
maison blanche
la course au vaccin signé walid bennani
regarder trouver l'antidote celui qui
permettra de sauver des millions de vies
voilà l'objectif numéro un des grands
laboratoires
aujourd'hui les gouvernements sont
dallas temps de la recette miracle
et dans cette course un sentiment semble
dominer
que le meilleur gagne oui nous avons
très bien travaillé celui qu'il
obtiendra sera très fier de le donner de
le développer nous verrons ce qui se
passera
celui qui l'obtient nous pensons que
c'est génial nous allons travailler avec
eux ils ont travaillé avec nous
également
si nous l'obtenons nous allons
travailler avec eux donald trump tente
d'éteindre la dernière polémique
en effet le laboratoire français sanofi
a assuré dans un premier temps que les
états unis seront les premiers servis
si un vaccin était découvert un choix
prioritaire qui a scandalisé dans
l'hexagone et obliger l'exécutif à
réagir je viens de le rappeler à serge
weinberg qui préside sanofi cette grande
entreprise profondément française il m'a
donné toutes les assurances nécessaires
quant à la distribution en france d'un
éventuel vaccin sanofi
la chine n'est pas en reste de la
compétition mondiale et vient d'annoncer
que cinq vaccins expérimentaux antique
qu'ovide 19 et est actuellement testé
sur l'homme 2575 volontaire au total ont
été vaccinées dans le cadre de
différents projets et aucun effet
indésirable majeur n'a été rapporté
le gouvernement a ajouté que la phase 2
de tous les essais cliniques
actuellement en cours sera terminée
d'ici juillet sans donner toutefois de
date de commercialisation etats-unis
france chine mais aussi grande bretagne
un laboratoire du sud de l'angleterre
travaillent sur un vaccin qui seraient
prescrits par voie orale et pourraient
être envoyées par la poste
nous avons vraiment besoin du soutien du
gouvernement car à partir de juillet
nous devrions fabriquer des millions de
doses
nous ne devrions pas attendre d'avoir
obtenu l'approbation réglementaire
faites le maintenant c'est relativement
peu compte l l'appui du gouvernement
l'approbation des autorités publiques
pour un de passage obligé avant la
diffusion d'un vaccin au brésil le
dernier ministre de la santé a
démissionné après des divergences avec
son président notamment sur
l'utilisation de la controversée
chloroquine pas de partage
d'informations ou de convergence à
l'échelle internationale européenne ou
encore national
et pourtant la recherche avance très
bien nous avons de bonnes raisons d'être
suffisamment optimiste quant au fait
qu'en fin de compte
certains vaccins seront efficaces
plusieurs technologies ont été abordés
ici et sont à l'étude et je serai donc
surpris si au bout du compte nous
n'aurons pas de vaccin disponibles pour
le commis de 19 avec plus de 100 projets
et une dizaine d'essais cliniques en
cours l'agencé européenne du médicament
prévoit qu'un vaccin pourrait être prêt
dans un an
cette belle initiative à présent en
tunisie mille repas par jour c'est le
défi que s'est lancé un restaurateur de
la banlieue ouest de tunis dans les
quartiers les plus défavorisés
il vient en aide à ceux qui ont été le
plus touchés par la crise
face aux aides de l'état qui peine à
arriver ce chef d'entreprise tente donc
de soulager le quotidien de plusieurs
dizaines de personnes qui affluent
chaque jour
le reportage dans la banlieue ouest de
tunis est signée bassam chebbi et les
airs nasri comme tous les jours depuis
plus de dix ans c'est le même rituel
pour ali restaurateurs dalle kabaria
réception des dons alimentaires
organisation des tâches
objectif sortir un repas complet destiné
aux nécessite de la capitale une
véritable course contre la montre pour
ce chef d'entreprise qui a décidé après
la révolution d'offrir chaque année un
repas pour permettre au plus grand
nombre de rompre le jeûne en ce mois de
ramadhan une initiative devenue une
tradition mais qui a dû s'adapter cette
année avec la crise du colis 19 années
nous avons vu commencer à travailler 25
jours avant le ramadan on a commencé à
distribuer des repas ceux qui
travaillent dehors aux familles les plus
démunies aux étudiants subsahariens
que ce soit dans la maison dans les
foyers bien ce sont des personnes qui
ont très peu de moyens qu'ils ne peuvent
pas sortir cette année à cause du
coronavirus on a multiplié nos
livraisons
il y a même des familles entières qui
viennent nous voir des fois des familles
qui n'ont rien du tout à manger à la
tête de cette brigade de bénévoles un
chef qui chaque année met son temps et
son savoir faire au service des
nécessiteux un engagement qui a pris
cette année une toute autre tournure
bonjour chef on a quoi menu aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui au menu série pisser briques
salade de poivrons
et cailles rôties qu'est ce qui a changé
pour vous cette année il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont changé cette année on a
dû travailler beaucoup plus car la
demande était plus importante
on a commencé directement avec plus de
700 repas et maintenant avec le ramadan
on dépasse facilement les mille et on
attend même les 1200 repas par jour il
arrive certaines fois où on a plus de
nourriture à distribuer alors je me mets
à cuisiner quelque chose rapidement pour
ne laisser personne mourir de faim comme
chaque jour depuis dix ans ce sont pas
moins de mille repas qui sont distribués
avec la crise du coronavirus la crise
sanitaire a laissé place à une réelle
crise sociale qui attire de plus en plus
de personnes des chômeurs des mères
isolées et des familles nécessiteuses
des étudiants subsahariens ou de simples
voyageurs
il se donne comme tous les jours rendez
vous chez ali avant le coucher du soleil
alors là vous commencez la distribution
là on vient de commencer la distribution
est en priorité les étudiants
subsahariens qui viennent de loin et on
veut leur permettre de rentrer
rapidement chez eux et surtout parce
qu'ils sont de passage chez nous comme
vous pouvez voir le premier groupe
d'étudiants vient d'arriver lui par
exemple vient chercher à manger pour
bienvenus
3 4 5 6
mais on n'a pas de napa ya pas de
famille ici et puis vous voyez il ya en
plus haut si on a moins et on a couru
navire turin n'a pas d'argent
le peu qu'on nous envoie en coopération
pour acheter on peut pas acheter de
nourriture c'est pourquoi on revient
tout le temps ici pour engager de plus
pour qu'on puisse garder l'argent qu'ils
envoient une fille voyez avec le
confinement et l'arrêt de nombreuses
activités
le nombre de nécessiteux a connu un bond
sur l'ensemble du territoire
creusant davantage cette fracture
sociale qui fragilise l'essor de cette
toute jeune démocratie où un quart de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
mais les initiatives citoyennes ne
m'entend tunisie tout comme à lille sont
nombreux à travers tout le pays à
apporter leur contribution pour soulager
ce qui semble avoir été abandonnée par
un système encore bien fragile et timide
né de la révolution de 2011
direction la côte d'ivoire à présent
abidjan la capitale qui concentre la
quasi totalité des cas de coronavirus
mais le gouvernement a décidé
d'assouplir les mesures de confinement
terminé le couvre-feu pour la capitale
économique et les célèbres maquille ses
petits bars restaurants particulièrement
apprécié des ivoiriens ils ont ouvert
donc après presque deux mois de
fermeture et c'est un soulagement pour
les restaurateurs et les clients francs
soit ischémique
difficile de cacher sa joie à youpougon
commune de la banlieue d'abidjan lé
célèbre maquis sont pris d'assaut
une affluence qui fait suite à
l'allègement des mesures par le
gouvernement avec la levée du couvre-feu
et la réouverture de ces petits bars
restaurants très prisé par les ivoiriens
après presque deux mois de restrictions
une réouverture sous condition du
respect des gestes barrières lavage
régulier des mains port du masque
distanciation physique de - m en fait je
veux massivement le gouverneur d'avoir
occasionné cela parce que vraiment on
souffrait aussi fade copie mercredi 19
mai maintenant que tout en vrai qu'il ya
des mesures pour respecter bon je pense
que vraiment ça bon repas pascal vincent
sommes abrités déjà à être continuée et
plus encore la communauté au fait tu
transformes il ya un peu pour vraiment
faire président l essentiel on respecte
pas le pouvant les lieux de spectacles
cinémas bars et boîtes de nuit reste en
revanche fermée pour les 5 millions
d'habitants de la capitale économique et
sa région
les établissements d'enseignement du
primaire jusqu'au supérieur reprendront
leurs activités eux le 25 mai tandis que
les frontières restent toujours fermés
au moins jusqu'au 31 mai et c'est la fin
de ce journal à merci de votre fidélité
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
et
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à levin et quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils n'étaient pas préparés
mais les villes elles se sont connectés
tout de suite entre elles pour voir
comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment est
ce qu'elles peuvent transformer après la
pandémie la crise maintenant à fait bien
comprendre qu'on peut pas s'oublier des
banlieues on peut pas oublier les
quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement ils font partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle ne part pas seulement d'elle-même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]